I'm I'm scared it's gonna be okay take  one look scared it's gonna be okay Oh  someone must make the ultimate sacrifice  so let's decide is playing on Thursday  Night Football but that's only a four  day turnaround for answering this week's  game will be exclusively on myspace with  our worst broadcast team some little guy  [Music]  first team selected is the Dolphins  garage coach put her name in like a  thousand times  a man whose bucket is this fine the  Chiefs only four days to gameplan all  right how about the Bears okay we  already doing it I mean we already did  it  Matt Park he can't hurt you anymore no  no we must give the football gods an  unexcited matchup tight Josh yokomen  Thursday game we are all day  hey you yeah all freakin hundred  thousands of you flippin listen to me  I'm peeled about the M effing lurkers  watching RBS so subscribe this cheney  channel or GT the fluff Oh daddy says  subscribe